some dirt on it
yeah is that why you stuck your um
dick in the soil
oh rub some dirt on it you [ __ ] the
earth did you really well when i was a
kid i dug a hole in the earth and i had
made love to the earth but i felt like
it was more of a spiritual thing were
you sober when you did that no i was
yeah i was a kid yeah yeah yeah why
well because it's a non-social thing to
do
oh
yeah so you're implying that charles
bukowski just did it all the time
i just i mean you know that's just a
wild decision to make like usually you
do that on shrooms or something feeling
wrong with the earth yeah start making
out with the ground and then you dug a
hole you actually took the time to dig
all right well i was how big was the
hole
well i was 12 so just a little
little tiny yeah yeah did you glue it up
or you just went in because that's gonna
dude it's dirt no dirt is it if you do
that in l.a that's dry soil when i lived
in the suburbs it was soft on the dog i
also want to i would also want to say to
you that um
the first time we ever met yeah no no i
i know i know you heard some things i
said this is the only reason i'm here
it is because your little [ __ ] tiger
belly crew
are being are being misinformed yeah
what did they call you people the tiger
bellies sleepers
he just ignored me yeah he didn't get a
picture with me or anything that's not
how it went down
at all
shame on you no first of all michael i
want to say this don't stand up because
it doesn't look any different to sitting
down
you son of a [ __ ] it's like this you
son of a [ __ ] it's like you leaned
forward
i was very funny
very funny but let me see go ahead go
ahead i'll tell you the way it went down
give your version yeah and i'll give
mine okay
for the what are they called again
sleepers sleepers okay so um
every once in a while because you know
joe rogan is a stand-up he's a long-time
friend of mine i've known him for
20 years 25 years um love him
great guy but um so a lot of you know
i'm a huge ufc fan so who's that little
guy from sacramento that i like you're
right
right you're our father man you nice guy
we hug this and that but then when i saw
bisping michael you for the first time
there i literally
was struck i was just like oh [ __ ]
that's michael bisping right
and i tried to come up to you and i said
you were very nice but i said hey man
i'm a big fan and you were you know
because when i walked i was at um the
the grocery store and people come up to
me and go oh you're very funny and you
want to be cordial right but i also
if that person that said hi to me was
josh groban
right
right okay and i blew him off right i
bet that josh groban would probably be a
little mad so he was at the comedy store
where first i've never i don't know who
josh robin is
okay so i've got zero context of what
you're saying an opportunity
is at the office
so when michael's business was there he
said very nice but he kind of just
walked away and i wanted some you know
maybe did you ask for the photos no i
didn't really okay but he did walk away
though already it's a different version
of the story
already and here's the reality yeah so
and i'm not when i say this yeah by the
way yeah by the way massive fan hence
why i'm here hence why i drove up from
[ __ ] orange county thank you did an
audition and i waited for three and a
half hours my vision was at 5 30. i was
half asleep half an hour okay yeah yeah
i'm just pounding some coffee now i'm
drinking this shite try and stay awake
and i'm very happy to be here you're a
hilarious comedian
i've never met you before i don't okay
hold on i know we're getting to the
point
the long suffering mrs bisping that's at
home god bless her she doesn't get out
very often you know she's got three kids
i travel a lot i took her out we went
out for a nice dinner and we went to go
watch some comics and a lot of the time
i'm not trying to say that i'm a [ __ ]
big deal or anything like that yeah but
a lot of time you stop and you take
pictures and this and that and then
after a while you've got to say okay
because i'm here with my wife
and i've done about 10 pictures in a row
while she's standing there like a
[ __ ] lump of cheese right doing
nothing so then after that i'm like okay
all right all right babe let's go in
and then you after that i said i'm not
now sorry mate we're done picture time
is over
right you should start doing this now
let me say something right so when you
or not fair sorry if i didn't put a
random stranger before my wife mmm i i
i'm so sorry you know i know you're the
great one the great bobby lee and the
comedy store is your house and you're
totally right it is your house but
we've never met and that's the mother of
my children right you know what and the
way it's okay i accept your apologies
get your [ __ ] answers it's fine it's
fine [ __ ] pause out of my face right
you you weren't to know about it right
you weren't denied all right he was
devastated though he called me
immediately after he ran to the parking
lot and he was like you can't you won't
believe what happened i just got turned
down
well for one right
but no but can i say say this please can
i say this please go ahead you did give
me a photo i did yes afterwards i
remember i was telling you
yes
with diaz and i walked up because when
you were talking to diaz
you know that then i seized my
opportunity and we took the photo you
know what i was just talking out of my
ass right just talking [ __ ] or whatever
yeah i'm not thinking that you're ever
gonna [ __ ] hear it
it's okay
i do it all the time if i was held
accountable
for every piece of dog [ __ ] that came
out of my mouth yeah
i'd probably be in prison yeah you know
or or you know excommunicated from
whoever i know and you know i want to
say this too is is that because never
let the truth get in the way of a good
story right you know go out i feel like
that's right
write that down
write it down i've never heard it before
what is you with your asians right now
man what do you mean with the yeah i
mean it's a [ __ ] chinese brother
okay can i give my side now yeah go
ahead and thanks
so as he was pacing around the room
basically sucking his own [ __ ] okay i
i had to tell him that you know he's not
as cool as he thinks and the reason that
i said that is because he was like
really really really really really i
mean by i mean sucking his dick like he
was really sucking his dick that day
so i was like you don't even know like i
can't share certain joys with him like
he doesn't understand memes
he doesn't understand like the
meme structure how they work why they're
funny i do
i do can i just say this
i'm sorry are you done with your
testimony no not yet okay defend it
finish let's defend it and i can't and
like i
like i can't share certain joys of like
irony with him like i i don't he doesn't
know anything between 1998
and today
like he doesn't know anything about
mainstream anything so i can't joke he
doesn't get like references about what i
think are funny about like
late 90s stuff or early 2000 because i
think that he just checked out of the
pop culture from that date
so like even about like the fire
festival when i was trying to explain
why
it was so funny
that when it when it did happen he had
never heard of it before
he's just so um
he's very very in touch with a lot of
things that are very cool and obscure
but very out of touch with like more
mainstream stuff that's i've always been
like that though
okay like today in the car i asked we
drove by a photo a a poster of
ariana grande
okay
now
because of
my obsession with the voice
and auditioning shows singing talent i'm
beginning to like now i have on my ipad
um playlists that i've made and one of
them is called cheese
so anything cheesy that i think is
cheesy and i have all that [ __ ] beyonce
i have
mariah carey i have whitney i have all
that [ __ ] because growing up i just
didn't care about people who could sing
good
i cared about more like
you know street
you know like the velvet underground
like kind of street you know
art art rock
pretty much like the talking head you
know things are a little weird you know
so but now
so we're driving by and i'm like how did
she just get discovered i asked her yeah
she's like she's a disney girl whatever
because she was married to pete uh
davidson because i know pete yeah
engaged
so tell me what happened so i'm i'm
asking because i want to get educated
yeah i could just look at that poster
and go [ __ ] her yeah i don't want to
know this i don't give a [ __ ] about her
you know what i mean she's wearing a
little [ __ ] bunny rabbit thing with a
little ears
batwoman mask you know but i'm
interested who is that you know tell me
about beyonce yeah i ask beyonce babe
that's how you beyonce yeah is that
what's her name it's beyonce but you've
been thinking oh yeah yeah
yeah
but you know what when i said beyonce i
said that's what i thought her name was
for like nine years
but since you've been correcting me i at
nights i lay in bed and i go beyonce
beyonce you practice i try to reprogram
my mind
so that i know that it's beyonce
[Music]
instead of beyonce okay and so when i
was came back from coachella i was like
babe destiny's child was there she
brought out kelly and michelle and he
was he was just like who the [ __ ] are
they
haley michelle obama who the [ __ ]
nobody brought the bomb
why would i care though
right it's like it's just like not
knowing who michael jordan is you know
like they're so massive right like but
he can i'll give you can i just
i'm still in court yes yes i want to
give you another
example of why
what
so how am i going to defend myself here
so basically
if i sometimes i go to an american
an american citizen yeah and they're
wearing an la rams jersey
and they'll go regrets they'll go
we're in the super bowl yeah
oh
interesting
so you know
our tight end he's really killing it
oh
i'm sure he is
i try to get involved right
the past interference on that double
back
whatever they say you know what i mean
yeah he tracked back and the passing of
friends was like the rookie the but the
rookie of the year yeah he really saved
beyonce
and i'll listen to all that i'll go yes
yeah right i try to be open to it right
but if i then go
hey
you know eric cantona wow he was great
right
and they were like
who's eric cantona
oh one of the greatest french soccer
players
of the history of the world
more people know him
then what the [ __ ] your stupid ramps
than you're talking about
they don't know but i don't judge them
from not knowing because they just don't
know
yeah right but they should but in my
mind they should but they don't
so my point is you can't know everything
kalala rebuttal you can't know
everything of course not but
as a comedian as somebody who's supposed
to be a to have a running commentary on
all things pop culture politics i think
that you should be on the up and up
about certain things like
like
who cardi b is
so my act would be cardi b wow the bell
bottom she was wearing at that disco jet
the bell button
at the disco jet was like
so in fashion what's up
all right what do you want me to do i
just i i think that it's just good i
don't know i'm just making it up
i think that there's a social
responsibility for you as like a
podcaster to at least know
sir a little thing a little about
everything he's standing everyone and
i'm not doing that i love you this is a
very i'm having a very happy advice like
i'm having a very i'm having a very
happy debate with you and i'm not i'm
not going to start if i love you so much
okay and you're doing your your points
are so good and my points are going
we're just having like an i'm just tired
of you saying raise the roof and i'd
like
also that's the core that's the core i'm
sitting back down now let's go
because i know
you know i'm not i can't but you
you've never held a relationship so many
names i want to say i can't do it didn't
you like [ __ ] a grandma in like the back
seat of her like caravan oh yeah and
they're like dude okay so i was in
i was in sacramento
i'm sorry i don't know why that's why
there's a little i bet you have no gigs
in sacramento i have a couple i've had a
couple but it's just funny because it's
just you know you had sex with a grandma
it's called sacrimento
my brain's weird i don't know
a weird joke in my head so
there's this
if you guys ever seen the public
francisco video
where he has that mental breakdown on
stage and that's the same club
oh yeah so it's it's called the
sacramento punch line
and it's in a mini mall
and it's very depressing i like the
punchline chain
and i love
life nation i love molly and who books i
i'm grateful thank you it's next new
mattress though but it's next to a
mattress store in this little weird
mini and so anyway i was with kevin
christie who very funny
actor and comedian and
after the show you know i sometimes take
photos with fans and this old lady came
up to me
and she got very
funny young man or something like that
and she gave me a handshake
here you know what i mean and then there
was a note
right oh and then i opened it she was
calling me you know i mean i think
you're cute or whatever
so after the show i was with kevin i'm
like do you believe this
and kevin goes are you kidding me she's
hot
she was she was a grandma though no she
was a grandma but she was like imagine
like um i'm thinking gray hair
think what's celebrity what's like
celebrating
um a cindy crawford but 55. oh wait wait
wait awesome
yeah she had like breast implants oh i
totally thought there was like a walker
no no no i don't do i don't know cocoon
[ __ ] she said
she
well the stories who gives a [ __ ] about
that then if she's a hot chick
now man
[Laughter]
this is an accomplishment i always say
like helen mirren is one of the hottest
women yeah she's like in between helen
mirren and cindy cruz and cindy crawford
in that ballpark i'm doing a lot okay
yeah did she have a um a mole
her neck was very wrinkly
her hands were very wrinkly but that
well done the nails yeah but she's like
she keeps she keeps up but she's still
[ __ ] old older woman yeah but all
right and also i was
at that time
i'm 47 now
35. um
okay
well i appreciate the story i'll say
that i appreciate the story a little bit
more story's
no it was a higher grade wing i just
remember there being wings okay right
chicken wings
you have the ones that you eat yes yeah
i love them yeah great i love them right
so good delicious kitchen24 has got some
great ones if you haven't ever tried
them yeah i want to go that wasn't a
plug by the way that was just like i've
never had their wings their hot wings
are incredible
the pineapple on kawenga right yeah
chicken one
kitchen 24 24.
okay anyway okay yeah back to the yeah
all right
so i remember afterwards she had a
bronco
right oh so even cooler than this then
she had
toys
wait so i thought it was like a toyota
sienna no there was toys all over the
[ __ ] you're making it sound like it
was like detroit rock city remember the
part where she like puts her foot on his
dick and he jizzes his pants you
remember that movie no i didn't see that
okay yeah yeah this is sounding like
it's that scene yeah there's like you're
in a car
she's a cougar well i'm telling you
right now i didn't see so i'm not you
know i mean this is not the scene of the
movie this actually happened to me i
don't know maybe it's the mandela
mandela
we've talked about that before great
effect it's a great effect yeah yeah
yeah
yeah it happened to me recently yeah
what's one of them um
life is like
a box of chocolates i've said that so
many times i know that's not what it
means
but it wasn't me it was forrest gump
that's your mandela effect yeah
wow yeah yeah that's good and there was
her grandkids
toys all over the things and i remember
how the you know what i mean okay and
making out with her and she pulled out a
titty
and her titty was a tit job but the but
the
the nipple part ariel was wrinkly
but it was fine i liked it
nipples actually stay intact sweetie so
that's [ __ ] no it was like it seemed
older like like oh it was really maybe
protruded out like really breastfed
before yeah yeah yeah aged yeah it
looked aged it's like whiskey like a
fine whiskey yeah yeah yeah i sucked on
it oh my god like that yeah i stopped
like oh my god something is tough
i did like that
like bone marrow i stopped i sucked and
goat cheese came out
oh my god i just got a burst of goat
cheese
right wait did anything come out no no
no okay yeah and i actually like gold
bond
but what happened was
her
at the second night she brought her
grandson who was 12
to meet me before the show because he
was a mad tv fan so that was a little
bit and then i just like i can't this is
anywhere so the first night you did
stuff no we i just sucked on her titty
that's it that's it and made out with
her okay yeah yeah i didn't know why we
went in the next story but um
i liked it
bobby thinks that certain people should
be treated better than certain people uh
oh
spaghetti
spaghettio not not we're not gonna talk
about it you can always defend yourself
but you said to be honest so i was yeah
but you're the way you said it these
phrases are difficult okay what you just
said right oh god
it sounds bad the way you said it okay
well hold on i'll try to make it nice no
i could i could try to justify what i'm
saying okay well let me finish then no
my point is this wait wait hold on i
haven't said anything
all right
when we're in a restaurant and he
doesn't get special treats no no no
no that's nervous that never happened
no my point is this
like if he has to wait like the other
people no no no no no
no no no no babe come on let's go
he's honestly out honestly all right
it's not honestly at all oh another
thing that i want to say okay okay
though no another thing there's another
thing i really want why can't i defend
the other one time
so lately he's been saying i really need
to get help i really need you know to
see a therapist i need to go to retreat
i was like yes yes yes all of the above
i support you and whatnot he was like i
want to go to this particular institute
and i'm like yes i'll sign you up you
know let me whatever i need to do for
the papers right it's good yeah and then
i'm like whoa he's really into this yeah
yeah and then he was like do you know
that
orlando bloom
and um katy perry have been there also
um justin bieber is supposed to be
headed there so
um yeah um that's oh that's why i want
to go
and so i've i i thought about this
and i think that your king even though
he doesn't want to admit he wants to be
the everyday man he doesn't want to rub
you know he doesn't want a hollywood
schmooze
there's a part of him
that's a very hollywood schmoozy
and he wants
he wants to be in that club
he wants to like just casually like be
friends with justin bieber
don't know why
but he does defend it
did you not want me to mention that
that's fine i'm gonna try to defend
myself and when his manager abby was
like this shit's expensive why where the
[ __ ] would you pay for this place you
know blah blah and he was like
goes there
true or false bobby true or false that
would never happen no one said objection
objection objection objection objection
okay here's here's the deal here's the
deal guys um slepkin's talking now real
okay
and i will admit to i will admit to some
things that i'm not i'm not proud of
okay
now sometimes when i'm at the comedy
store
and
john mayer says hello to me
it feels good that's cool yeah that's
cool like yeah
[ __ ] john mayer just gave me a hug yeah
right mm-hmm
you know
chappelle the other day what took a
selfie with me
hey let's take a photo you know i felt
good yeah
does that feel
does that feel different than when like
a fan wants to take a photo
it feels a little different
with you
yeah if if somebody's some random guy
like a valet yeah let's take a photo i
want to yeah whatever i don't say no
yeah i take a photo chappelle asks for a
photo i take a photo yeah are those two
the same they feel different to me
i don't know where you're getting at my
point is is this is that um
with
you here's my and we don't have to take
this whole thing out but what i'm saying
hey i believe in you you got it
here's what i want to say you got that
you know
what
i've had arguments with kalila about how
some people are more important than
other people and this and that right
so for instance i don't believe she
doesn't believe that
so
this is going to sound terrible
but
you know if a man if they found that you
know if they found
they found a man
a regular man in antarctica okay and he
was in a block of ice it was frozen
right
right and they did did they saw him yeah
they saw him all right i'm with you
buddy come on buddy they thought and
they go who is this guy and they go his
name is john smith yep what does he do
pocahontas husbands no not even no john
atherington
frozen body of tom hanks
yeah so what's more important
i would say
in the history of time and history of
the world in terms of like what people
care about
is it more interesting that it was just
a coal miner
who slipped and fell or if it was like
steve mcqueen yeah i'll say i'll say it
is more interesting right it's more and
also more people would be bummed about
it more people would be bummed about
steve mcqueen oh my god that's worse
let's say steve mcqueen had disappeared
yeah right off the face of this planet
one of the biggest actors of the early
70s right
and then they found his frozen body or
some random guy comparatively speaking
john effing's d that's john atherington
steve mcqueen would be more of a thing
it's more important
but that's not what i was saying i i
don't know
we've had arguments like that before i
have a question i'm just telling you i
have a question for you then i have a
question why every s new restaurant that
we go to
if the owner or someone in that place
doesn't know who you are
it automatically the dumplings aren't
good
like
yesterday
yesterday
can you hear me though i can't hear you
okay i'll tell you guys i'll tell you
guys
yesterday okay yesterday we ordered a
bunch of dumplings and he was like yeah
they're all right are they good are they
good and all of a sudden
he
um later on the owner strolls in and
then he takes a picture with bobby
and then bobby sits back down he was
like oh my god these dumplings are so
good
i all said everything tastes good to him
and he he
i don't understand that how why
why does
maybe life tastes better when you're
acknowledged maybe i'll
maybe that's it
well i guess you could say in a
restaurant setting i guess it's part of
the ambiance so you're like including
all the senses of like oh it was nice
customer service it was
knowledge here's the deal here's the
deal defend it you're back i'm back
thank you
what you're saying to me right now
has rung true
and i'm get i'm being i'm being able to
see myself right in a light that's ugly
it's an ugly light i think it's cute no
no it's an ugly light
and it makes me fee seem despicable no
it does
and um
in in the light of the evidence shown
before me
it's either run hide
or face it
those are my options
those are three options yeah
i'm going to face it
say congratulations congratulations
thank you
okay
so
from this day forth
right
get your [ __ ] smile off your face
george i [ __ ] swear to god i'll gouge
your eyes out i will gouge your [ __ ]
eyes out through the glass thank you
from this day forward i am a changed man
okay
the dumplings are gonna be good as
is hear what i'm saying yes